ready here we go  [Music]  tuna boat hi  oh cool is this  this is Cowboys versus Indians right is  that what we're watching right I think  it's an alien what sweet but how  [Music]  [Music]  what yup  yeah I thought the other ones were worse  oh yeah yeah but it still looks pretty  kick-ass leave it without I'm getting  immune no I'm lying that that still  actually grossed me out now that I think  about my [ __ ] yeah there's so many  videos about this game that we've done  so far so you can check out dams gaming  channel you can check out Alyssa's  fun-ass channel and you can subscribe to  the real rejects and you follow each of  us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter  there you go we plugged everything  reaction it completes